pardon mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous avez voté une disposition
qui interdit d'office et d'emblée la
fermeture d'un ensemble d'établissements
recevant du public
par catégorie vous avez voté une
disposition qui si elle devait être
appliquée empêcherait à tout moment et
quelles que soient les conditions de
fermer une catégorie d'établissement
quelles que soient les conditions
sanitaires y compris dans les zones
d'alerté maximale et vun il leur est
alors que la possibilité pour un préfet
de constater qu'un établissement en
particulier pose des difficultés au
regard de la sécurité sanitaire est donc
fermé a posteriori vous avez apercevons
je le redis parce que c'est important
parce que en étant quand ici une fois
ici pour partager les choses vous votez
la réouverture des bars la rouverture
des discothèques dans toutes les villes
de france c'est un fait c'est ce que
vous avez voté tout à l'heure dans ce
malgré tout que cet échange même s'il
présente un caractère rétrospectif et
utile et je reconnais avec notre
collègue max brisson que les
explications qui nous ont été données
par le ministre postérieurement vote
aurait mérité de nous être donné avant
le vote
je veux vous dire que le ministre a
raison sur le plan purement factuel il
ya dans la loi du 9 juillet une
disposition qui permet la fermeture
provisoire d'une ou de plusieurs
catégories d'établissements recevant du
public
quand il y à un risque dans ces
établissements de propagation de
l'épidémie
ce texte est dans la loi du 9 juillet et
l'amendement numéro 23 de nos collègues
du groupe socialiste supprime la faculté
pour les autorités sanitaires de fermer
des établissements recevant du public
est ce que c'est ce que vous avez
souhaité en votre temps cet amendement
ou es ce que vous avez plutôt penser que
cet amendement allé dans le même sens
que les amendements que vous avez
défendu
si vous avez pensé que
cet amendement de notes de nos collègues
du groupe socialiste permettait de
régler le problème que vous avez soulevé
je crois que vous êtes trompés alors je
me demande si la solution ne
consisterait pas à faire une seconde
délibération sur cet amendement numéro
puisque maintenant nous sommes
pleinement éclairé et si cet amendement
numéro 23
à l'issue de la seconde délibération
devait être écarté alors mes chers
collègues vos amendements pour
lesquelles j'ai dû émettre un avis
défavorable revivrai et vous auriez tout
le loisir de les voter si tel est votre
souhait je demande une seconde
délibération de cet amendement 23
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur ce
serait monsieur le rapporteur ça ne veut
pas avoir lieu maintenant ce sera la fin
du texte
la fin avant le vote final